this executive order signed by President
Trump starts a new policy on refugees
and immigration and Marilu see the
projection of the nation's foreign
terrorist and into the United States but
that's not what's really in this
executive order so let's go through it
first the order bans
all immigrants and visa holders from
seven majority Muslim countries from
entering the u.s. for at least 290 days
there is no security benefit Americans
are more likely to be killed by their
own clothes and by an immigrant
terrorist nobody in the US has been
killed in a terrorist attack by
immigrants from these particular seven
nations but the u.s. is now treating
everybody from these countries as if
they are a suspect computational
biologist Samira as Gauri said she now
can't come here to work on immuno
genomics at Harvard
oscar-winner Ashgar Farhad II can't come
back to the u.s. for the Oscars where
he's nominated again Sudanese dr. su ha
ha ha Shama hurried back to the US to
begin work at the prestigious Cleveland
Clinic only to be put back onto a plane
out hours later but in addition to these
travel bans the executive order also
begins a fundamental shift in American
refugee policy the order halts nearly
all refugee admissions for 120 days and
admissions of Syrian refugees
indefinitely and it says in the future
refugees will only be admitted from
countries that have sufficient
safeguards in place to ensure the
security and welfare of the United
States this is the opposite of how the
US has defined refugees in the past
people fleeing persecution and violence
that their own governments cannot or
will not protect them from
and this comes at a time when the world
faces its biggest refugee crisis since
World War two one in 122 people
worldwide are displaced and those
fleeing the largest humanitarian
emergency of our time the Syrian civil
war are the ones singled out by Trump
for harsher restrictions if you're
worried about us terrorist attacks like
9/11 San Bernardino or the Orlando pulse
shooting this order would have presented
exactly none of them but there is an
exception for some kinds of refugees as
it relates to persecuted Christians do
you see them as kind of a priority here
and their support unit had been horribly
created the US will allow members of
religious minorities in the individuals
country of nationality during the
120-day ban and prioritize them
thereafter you know if you were a
Christian in Syria it was impossible
very very at least very very tough to
get into the United States if you or
Muslim you could come in but if you were
a Christian it was almost impossible in
fact half of refugees in the past few
years were Christian refugees from Syria
reflected the country's religion
composition almost entirely Muslim but
all this aligns of trumps anti-muslim
promises throughout the campaign Donald
J Trump is calling for a total and
complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States
some spoke about taking an America first
approach at its inauguration
from this day forward it's going to be
only America first America first this
executive order shows how much that
vision aligns with the original America
first movement that movement thought
American isolationism - they were
against American intervention in World
War two that attitude resulted in the
infamous decision in June 1939 to turn
away to st. Louis that ships had 937
Jewish refugees aboard fleeing another
hostile government hit
first they were turned away in Cuba a
minor st. Louis turned back from Cuba
then they approached Florida but the US
Coast Guard patrolling the waters kept
them away too they eventually
disembarked in Belgium the Netherlands
and France Jewish unfortunates without a
country permitted to land in Belgium
after five weeks of suspends afloat and
eventually hundreds died in Holocaust
since then the US government has been
the world's leader in resettling
refugees finally rejoining the State
Department website still bragged about
it claiming three million refugees to be
settled around all 50 states since 1975
and the Statue of Liberty bares these
goals to a plaque on the side of the
pedestal reads give me your tired your
poor your huddled masses yearning to
breathe free the wretched refuse of your
teeming Shore send these the homeless
tempest-tossed to me I lift my lamp
beside the Golden Door America hasn't
always lived up to these lofty goals but
since world war ii we've lived in an era
where the diversity of who gets to come
to the United States has gone up and up
a federal judge staged deportation of
those stuck in airports and it's the
confusion and the Trump administration
has already started scaling back far as
green card holders moving forward it
doesn't affect them but the Trump
administration is trying to end the era
when America didn't care the religious
law regardless of where you come from
legal challenges and protests around the
country continue to try to preserve
[Music]
you